es gibt immer etwas zu tun 15 jahre für
man ja und ihr mann danke jetzt schon
dass glänzenden house hotel
sie kümmert sich um die gäste eher um
die küche und sie haben das haus wieder
hoch gebracht
mittlerweile können sie auf eine ganze
reihe von auszeichnungen stolz sein
das hotel liegt malerisch am loch 4
ein altes herrenhaus aus dem 18
jahrhundert tourismus ist hier in den
westlichen heiland ein saisongeschäft
aber die sommermonate sind gut gebucht
zum fleisch gesellte sich das glück
harry potter natürlich wie in harry
potter filme die wir gedreht haben läuft
es bei uns in der lokhalle gegend
einfach phänomenal
die filmcrews haben oft hier im hotel
übernachten
many times elsewhere einem steinwurf vom
hotel entfernt wird es lieben fragen
über den weltberühmte glenn finden
viadukt harry potters zug vor harry
potter ergenzingen und seine umgebung
wahr eine abgelegene gegend an der
westküste schottlands jetzt ist die
region ein touristenmagnet
doch all das ist plötzlich bedroht durch
den brad pitt denn nach dem willen der
britischen regierung sind eu ausländer
als arbeiter bald nicht mehr willkommen
hängte der west gestern
ich glaube das problem ist dass sie
einfach nicht genügend arbeitskräfte
hier in der region haben um die
sommermonate zu überstehen
das ist ein echter kampf über die
lokalen jobcenter versucht aber die
haben nicht genügend leute locken es ist
einfach unmöglich dass fallende dem
posten und macht die britische regierung
ihre drohung wahr wäre man ja auch
persönlich betroffen
denn auch wenn sie schon fast 20 jahren
in großbritannien lebt
deutsche der tür von bergheim die kinder
waren schon schockiert als sie vom
wechsel gehört habe vor allem die kleine
und sie haben gesagt oh nein man geht
muss du weg und ich habe gesagt das wird
nicht passieren aber es ist ein riesen
thema in der familie und in der schule
osama live jetzt im frühling ist die
schottischen westküste ein
farbenprächtiges bilderbuch felde
gehütet blühende dienste und stille
bucht zweimal pro tag darf der zug in
der hochsaison an glenn finnen vorbei
er schlängelt sich durch die highlands
und schließlich am meer entlang
das kleine fische erziehen melek ist
endstation
rund 15.000 touristen besuchen es jeden
monat und der zug ist für die bewohner
der abgelegenen region so etwas wie ihr
persönliches harry potter wunder sagt
sein besitzer ihr zug ist wirklich
wichtig mich anschaut wie viele leute
wie ihr nachname bringen wieder für
dessen dann findet ja nur die eine
straße ist uns würden
denn fischerei gibt es in der kaum noch
statt dessen hotels restaurants cafés
ohne den tourismus wäre die region am
ende über 200.000 jobs hängen von ihm ab
dann kribbelt schon in der küche für das
abendessen er kultiviert die feine
schottische küche des grenzen hat sich
auch gastronomisch einen namen gemacht
das restaurant ist gut besucht um den
service aber kümmern sich ausschließlich
ausländer aus bulgarien ungarn litauen
monika arbeitet die erste saison hier
aber sie war schon öfter in
großbritannien hätte ich dieses mal
hierher gekommen bin war schon anders am
flughafen mit sie haben nicht gefragt
warum ich hierher komme auch constantin
ist einer von zehn eu ausländer die im
glänzenden hausarbeiten letztes jahr
noch war man aber dieses jahr ist er
schon stellvertretender hotelmanager
er kann nur hoffen dass es für ihn gut
weitergeht wenn das mit allen eu
arbeiten hier zur gleichen zeit passiert
dann gibt es wohl einen aufstand doping
denn ich glaube nicht dass die britische
wirtschaft ohne eu arbeiter überleben
kann
sie haben einfach nicht genug leute man
ja sagt ohne ausländer könnten sie zu
machen
immerhin hat sie für sich noch einen
plan b ein kleiner kater zu testen
ich könnte mich auch um die britische
staatsbürgerschaft bemühen
aber ich hoffe dass ich das nicht machen
ich wünsche mir immer noch dass alles in
ordnung und vernünftige regelungen für
eu bürger gemacht werden hier schon so
lange leben und auch bleiben wollen
draußen wird es abend und das gelingt
ihnen bekommt noch unerwarteten besuch
noch sind sie zuversichtlich hier dass
es am ende doch nicht so schlimm kommen
wird aber seitdem bracket referendum
leben sie mit einer bösen ahnung